[Música]
en la majestuosa catedral de cristo
salvador
los residentes de moscú celebran la
pascua con gran alegría y en presencia
de vladimir putin patria creel es un
aliado del presidente ruso durante el
fin de semana festivo pidió el fin de la
guerra en ucrania pero no la condenó
mientras que en jeff de pie dentro de la
iglesia de santa sofía el presidente
ucraniano entregó su mensaje de pascua a
la gente de
la gran festividad de hoy nos da la gran
esperanza y la creencia de que la luz
vencerá a la oscuridad el bien vencerá
al mal no podemos sólo si la vida vencer
a la muerte por lo tanto usan ya
inevitablemente vencerá paramos a
ucraína
con russian negándose a aceptar una
tregua de pascua las celebraciones de
este año han sido moderadas y realizadas
con temor a bombardeos y fuego de
artillería en sabori allá en el este de
ucrania cerca de la línea del frente los
fieles llegaron para recibir sus
bendiciones de pascua y luego partieron
rápidamente
no entramos a la iglesia hicimos todo
rápido recibimos nuestras bendiciones
del párroco y ahora vamos camino a casa
en casa tendremos una reunión con
nuestra familia y se unieran nuestros
vecinos este año todo se hace muy rápido
en el capitolio los fieles también
dieron gracias al presidente y al
ejército a nuestra nación siempre ha
estado unida y hoy estamos demostrando
que es imposible asustarnos
los funcionarios ucranianos han instado
a la gente a no quedarse en los
servicios este año debido a la
preocupación de que las iglesias puedan
ser blanco de ataques con misiles